[Musica]
ovunque siamo nati qualunque sia il
colore della nostra pelle o la lingua
che parliamo tutti siamo stati circa
nove mesi nel grembo materno
io addirittura l'ho dovuto condividere
con mia sorella
ed è con lei che ha inizio questa storia
ma che cos'è la pancia di una donna
incinta la pancia di una donna incinta è
una sfera di cristallo piena di sogni è
un atto di coraggio e ammettere ad alta
voce che futuro sarà decidere di avere
un figlio
significa scegliere la possibilità
l'allegria anche se può far male anche
se può toglierti il sonno o farti
sentire uno straccio io mi considero un
ambasciatrice di colori delle tante
sfere magiche di donne in giro per il
mondo
[Musica]
che cosa
sì dax
che
[Musica]
il mio viaggio
[Applauso]
il mio viaggio nel colore ha inizio dal
liceo artistico da una grande passione
per l'arte e dalla convinzione che in
qualche modo con i colori si potessero
trasformare le emozioni e così la
tristezza la immaginavo da grigio verde
da noi anziché gialla la immaginavo
beige lo sconforto lo immaginavo anziché
nero blu e la delusione nella bandiera
del brasile
credo che con i colori di 20 tutto più
bello è anche se all'università ho
scelto di studiare altro è il lavoro che
faccio ha ben poco a che vedere con il
mondo dell'arte
i colori in caso di emergenza nella
borsa li ho sempre portati con me è un
giorno l'emergenza è arrivata
mia sorella gemella venne ricoverata
incinta all'ospedale a causa di problemi
nella gestazione
io mi ricordo che era molto triste
nonostante la mia vicinanza fisica mi
sentivo impotente la osservavo guardavo
quel suo ombelico sporgente che sembrava
quasi di nasino di un bambino desideroso
di venir fuori allora preso una matita
per gli occhi due colori ad acqua che
avevo in borsa e decisi di riportare la
mia immagine mentale sulla sua pelle
fu un successo immediato la felicità di
mia sorella
l'entusiasmo della sua compagna di
stanza quello delle ostetriche delle
infermiere
mi diedero la percezione che in qualche
modo quel gioco che avevo appena fatto
potesse arrecare beneficio e definì quel
momento una missione sorriso ben
riuscita che poi è continuata grazie
alla potenza dei social network che mi
hanno permesso di proseguire e arrivare
fin qui grazie anche ad una mia amica
francesca che mi ha dato la possibilità
di giocare sulla sua pelle sulla sua
gravidanza quindi di testare i colori su
di lei è così colore dopo colore pancia
dopo pancia mi rendevo sempre più conto
che mi piaceva dialogare con queste
sfere maggio
e tanto quest'arte nas nasce in america
ma io l'ho completamente personalizzata
non completamente fatta mia le donne mi
contattano io le raggiungo e le
trasforma totalmente ognuna con un'opera
sempre diversa il rapporto che si
instaura con loro è uno scambio di
energie di tante storie
trascorriamo molte molte ore insieme e
mi ritrovo sempre ad un certo punto a
dipingere sul bambino che scalcia dalle
mamme viene sempre fame
questa storia mi ha dato una grande
possibilità quella di conoscere gran
parte dell'italia di conoscere tante
famiglie e tante storie ma non solo
anche all'estero in america in spagna in
germania francia in molti altri paesi
e così città come bari napoli roma
nocera inferiore
venezia e tanti altri tante altre città
sono sono diventate una mia seconda casa
in cui ho trovato parenti amici
familiari tutti intenzionati intenti ad
aiutarmi per vedere queste punch e
sorridenti realizzate quindi l'empatia
che si crea tra perfetti sconosciuti è
la cosa che più mi appaga in questo mio
percorso bellissimo
spesso mi domandano qual è la mia pancia
preferita la mia pancia preferita è
questa perché quella che più mi
rappresenta quella che più parla di me
non perché io sia cattiva sia ben chiaro
ma perché è una storia d'amore nel senso
più ampio del termine
la mia è un'arte a tempo è un'arte a
battiti e avrà la sua conclusione nella
realizzazione di un libro fotografico in
cui ci saranno tutti i colori dei miei
viaggi a far conoscere le pance nel
mondo l'obiettivo arrivare a 101 101
pance colorate 101 storia d'amore 101
sorrisi grazie
[Applauso]